und wir setzen nun die
haushaltsberatungen fort für die heutige
aussprache haben wir bereits am dienstag
eine redezeit von insgesamt neun stunden
beschlossen wir beginnen die heutigen
beratungen mit dem geschäftsbereich des
bundesministeriums für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz und das wort erhält für die
bundesregierung der bundesminister dr
robert habeck
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
guten morgen
[Musik]
lieber von nazi haben das dann ihre rede
mit der verstellung begonnen es wird von
zeitenwende gesprochen aber man würde
sie nicht sehen ich möchte für die
bundesregierung aber auch für mein
ministerium sagen man muss blind sein
wenn man sie nicht sie
hier
wir dürfen uns in einer grossen
geschwindigkeit von der abhängigkeit von
russischen fossilen energien nicht nur
von den fossilen energien sondern wir
kämpfen gegen eine infrastruktur die die
abhängigkeit noch vergrößert hat
gazprom besitzt den größten speicher in
deutschland der über den letzten sommer
gelehrt wurde als vorbereitung uns in
diesem winter zugänge rosneft besitzt
eine große ölraffinerie in
ostdeutschland nord stream 2 wurde
gebaut wir haben all das korrigiert oder
sind dabei es zu korrigieren wenn man
das nicht als zeitenwende als politische
sowohl in der qualität wie in der
quantität erkennt dann will man ist
nicht erkennen
[Applaus]
ja
wenn man sich davon unabhängig machen
will muss man noch für alternativen
sorgen das heißt wir bauen lng terminals
und wir kaufen die rohstoffe ein die wir
brauchen um diese allen die terminals zu
betreiben der qualitative unterschied
ist nicht ist nicht daher das
herkunftsland der qualitative
unterschied ist dass wir nie wieder uns
in die hand von einem lieferanten
alleine begeben wollen das was wir
machen ist die energieversorgung in
deutschland breite auf der und sicherer
aufzustellen der weg über die glasbrücke
wird immer kürzer werden je höher die
preise sind wir bauen die wasserstoff
infrastruktur auf wir sorgen dafür dass
der hochlauf von wasserstoff stattfindet
dafür bauen wir die erneuerbaren
energien nach jahren des stillstandes
mit großer dringlichkeit aus das gleiche
gilt für die netze und wir sorgen dafür
dass ich verstehe auch warum man darüber
so wenig redet denn das was man einspart
das sieht man ja nicht deswegen wird
über effizienz und einsparung zu wenig
geredet aber es macht keinen sinn auch
bei den hohen preisen dagegen an zu
subventionieren wenn wir den verbrauch
nicht reduzieren die effizienz nach
vorne zu bringen den abschied von
interessierten in den verbrauch mit
leibeskräften voran zu bringen das ist
das gebot der stunde und wo ich rolf
mützenich und britta haßelmann sie wir
hatten eine interessante nacht die zu
einem guten ergebnis geführt hat einem
guten ergebnis geführt hat dass gerade
in dem bereich der effizienz vorzeigbare
ja ich würde sagen ausrufezeichen setzen
wird wenn daher die parteivorsitzenden
das ergebnis des koalitionsausschusses
vorstellen so gibt eine zeitenwende so
wird eine zeitenwende gemacht so lösen
wir uns aus dem klammergriff der in den
letzten jahren entweder entweder durch
unwissenheit oder durch strategische
blindheit immer enger um deutschland
gezogen wurde ja wir sind noch nicht in
der lage ein sofortiges embargo auf
kohle auf öl oder auf gas aus russland
zu verhängen dass es zuzugeben und es
ist bitter genug das zuzugeben aber dass
wir das noch nicht können heißt nicht
dass wir nichts tun schritt für schritt
den wir jetzt schon dabei die
abhängigkeit von öl und von kohle und
von gas in der strategie zu reduzieren
die zahlen die ich am anfang des krieges
genannt habe sie stimmen jetzt schon
nicht mehr die bundesregierung und die
unternehmen dafür bedanke ich mich bei
den unternehmen wie mitziehen sind jetzt
schon dabei ein schrittweises embargo
umzusetzen meine damen und herren meine
damen und herren natürlich
verstehe
verstehe ich die dringlichkeit mit der
leute sagen macht doch schneller und
vielleicht vielleicht wäre ja auch ein
embargo dass jetzt sofort auf alle drei
rohstoffe verhängt wird der game changer
und vielleicht wäre da kriegt nach drei
spieltagen in der ukraine zu ende
vielleicht aber auch nicht und die
indizien wenn man sich anschaut wie die
russischen aggression in den ländern
davor sind sprechen er dagegen syrien
georgien der angriff auf die krim dieser
aktion bei dem angriff der annexion der
krim und sie alle sind jahre jahre her
teilweise
mehrere also fast ein jahrzehnt her wir
können also nicht sicher davon ausgehen
dass die maßnahmen ergreifen die wir
ergreifen könnten zu einem erfreulichen
ergebnis führen deswegen ist die politik
der bundesregierung nicht unbedacht zu
handeln sondern schritt für schritt die
voraussetzungen zu schaffen dass wir
außenpolitisch und
sicherheitspolitischen freiraum mehr
kämpfen um dann die maßnahmen auch
durchzuhalten die wir ergreifen das ist
das gebot der stunde eine kluge
umsichtige aber energische politik
vieles von dem was wir machen
unterstützen wir mit finanziellen
aufwendungen und zwar wenn ich auf der
haushalt von meinem ministerium schaue
mit erheblichen aufwendungen aber wir
sind auch dabei eine überförderung der
vergangenheit zurück zu fahren ich habe
schon als wir über die gebäudesanierung
gestritten haben gesagt subventionen
sind die ultima ratio in einer
marktwirtschaft sie sind notwendig um
die märkte noch nicht da sind aber da wo
die märkte schon funktionieren da kann
man sie auch zurücknehmen und ich muss
feststellen dass nach 16 jahren unions
geführter regierung wir eine über
subventionierung in vielen bereichen
haben teilweise glaubt man wo die leute
bewegen sich in deutschland nur noch
wenn man ihnen ein klaps einen
finanziellen klaps auf den hintern gibt
komisch dass wir ihnen erklären die
marktwirtschaft funktioniert und darum
geht es darum geht es jetzt in dieser
situation bei woha installation und bei
schwächelnder konjunktur richtig krise
und die kräfte des marktes zu entfalten
und zwar nicht blind zu entfalten
sondern ihm eine richtung zu geben eine
richtung die rohstoffverbrauch und
klimaschutz und unabhängigkeit
kombiniert mit wachstum und wohlstand in
diesem land das tun wir mit dem großen
geldern die meinem haus zur verfügung
gestellt worden die 200 milliarden für
den klima- und transformations- vor dem
grund haushalt der ungefähr elf
milliarden beträgt wir investieren in
wasserstoff wir investieren in
innovation wir investieren in cloud
technologie wir investieren in die in
die effizienz von antrieben und von
gebäuden so schaffen wir die neuen
märkte so schaffen wir innovation in
deutschland und so schaffen wir den
wettbewerb um die innovation und nicht
den wettbewerb darüber wer am längsten
im status quo für hart
meine damen und herren
heute vor einem jahr genau hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ein
wegweisendes urteil gefällt es lässt
sich zusammenfassen mit dem satz wer das
klima schützt schützt die freiheit das
haben die richterinnen und richter
damals geurteilt und diskret ist ging
wie einprägen durch die politische
landschaft
heute ein jahr nach diesem urteil muss
man übersetzen der darum kämpft sich von
den fossilen energien frei zu machen der
kämpft für die freiheit das war sehr
geehrte damen und herren das bedeutet
zeitenwende machen wir uns frei von den
fossilen energien erst aus russland dann
insgesamt so kämpfen wir für die
freiheit so kämpfen wir für die ukraine
für die ukraine für die freiheit
dankeschön
der bundesminister für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz der erste redner in der
debatte über seinen einzelplan 09 im
bundeshaushalt 20 22 die gegenrede wird
jetzt kommen von andreas jung der ist
sprecher für klimaschutz und energie in
der unionsfraktion
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen jetzt vor einer woche hatte
präsident zielinsky hier zugeschaltet im
bundestag gesprochen
er hat gesprochen von bomben und raketen
auf wohnung auf krankenhäuser
auf kindergärten auf schule er hat
gesprochen von nord stream 2 hat in
diesem zusammenhang den ausdruck
gebrauchtes sei
zement für eine neue mauer zwischen
freiheit und unfreiheit in
europa
er hat an unsere historische
verantwortung für die ukraine appelliert
diese worte des frei gewählten
präsidenten der ukraine überfall von
putin mit an schrecklichen krieg die
wiegen schwer die treffen unser herz
unser gewissen und sie dürfen mich
folgenlos bleiben
und wir alle wir alle müssen uns
schreiben was hätten wir früher mehr tun
müssen wie müssen wir jetzt
konsequenz zeigen und was können wir
mehr tun die antworten sind nicht
einfach aber eines möchte ich sagen mit
blick auf die ankündigung putins von
gestern mit blick auf die sanktionierung
der russischen zentralbank und vor augen
das unermessliche leid der menschen in
mario tollen und in vielen anderen orten
in der ukraine wir dürfen in dieser
situation nicht hinter unsere eigenen
beschlüsse zurückgehenden unsere eigenen
sanktionen
unterlaufen
in einer anderen konstellation aber auch
schweren lage helmut schmidt als
bundeskanzler gesagt der staat darf sich
nicht erpressen lassen und heute gilt
das frei europa darf sich nicht
erpressen lassen und deshalb herr
minister und sehr geehrte damen und
herren der bundesregierung braucht es
hier auf jetzt eine klare eine
gemeinsame europäische antwort die
erwarten wir für die beratung der
nächsten teil
und der richtige weg ist alles zu tun um
unabhängig zu werden von russischen
importen bei der energie herr minister
auf diesem weg haben sie unsere
ausdrückliche unterstützung das ist
unser weg das ist richtig dass jetzt
genauso zu tun und ja da haben wir eine
gemeinsame grundlage nämlich den
beschluss des bundestages
klimaneutralität
2045 nach der entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts von der großen
koalition beschlossen von der ampel
übernommen und jetzt geht es darum
energiesicherheit und klimaschutz
zusammen zu bringen und deshalb ist es
notwendig dem weg den wir gehen nämlich
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien da
gibt es keinen stillstand es muss
beschleunigt werden es müssen massiv
beschleunigt werden die steigerung der
energieeffizienz die fortführung der
wasserstoff strategie das ist die
eigentliche antwort das muss
beschleunigt werden in diesem sinne
unterstützen wir auch das oster und bis
sommer pakete werden dass die inhalte
genau anschauen wir werden eigene
vorschläge machen aber dieses ziel
unterstützen wir und wenn gute
vorschläge machte dann in dem sinne wie
sie es beschrieben haben wenn
zusammengebracht wird die kraft der
natur und die stärke des marktes dann
werden wir das mit überzeugung im
bundestag unterstützen
neben muster und sommer paket braucht es
jetzt aber auch ein winterpaket es
braucht ein paket zur vorsorge auf den
kommenden winter das muss kurzfristig
auf den weg gebracht werden mit unserer
kurzfristigen antwort und mit der
vorsorge wie kommen wir wie könnten wir
über den nächsten winter kommen ohne
russische importe das muss jetzt
passieren und erstens ist dazu richtig
alles zu unternehmen um zusätzliche
kapazitäten zu erschließen und bei
anderen ländern als russland einzukaufen
in europa und international
das ist der richtige weg das
unterstützen wir
zweitens ist es richtig die konsequenzen
daraus zu ziehen dass unsere gasspeicher
zu beginn dieses winters nicht gefüllt
worden sonst zu guten teilen lernen war
der markt hat es hier eben nicht
gerichtet und das so lange und das
lotion lange gelten das wird so lange
gelten wie gazprom 20 prozent der
deutschen gasspeicher in seinem einfluss
hat und deshalb werden wir im bundestag
morgen dieses gesetz als union
unterstützen da gilt es jetzt
konsequenzen zu ziehen
drittels herr minister habe ich kann sie
angewandt es müsse auch über
einsparungen gesprochen werden und ich
sage ihnen wir sind bereit wenn sie
vorschläge machen ohne vorfestlegungen
mit ihm über die dinge zu sprechen die
in dieser schweren situation
möglich und vertretbar sind das ist auch
ein bestandteil dieses winterpaket ohne
vorfestlegung machen sie vorschläge
dafür wir werden darüber mit ihnen
sprechen die forderung ist darf keine
denkverbote geben die richtet sich nicht
nur an sie sondern die wollen wir auch
selber beherzigen aber vierter sie
richtet sich eben auch an sie und
deshalb ist unsere aufforderung dass sie
das tun was sie angekündigt haben
nämlich dass sie ergebnisoffen und ohne
vorfestlegung prüfen auf basis des
gemeinsamen bekenntnis zum
kohlekompromiss und zum ausstieg aus der
kernenergie was in dieser situation
möglich ist welche optionen es gibt bei
der modifizierung des stilllegungs fahrt
bei der kohle aber auch bei einem
möglichen weiterbetrieb der letzten drei
verbliebenen kernkraftwerke über den 31
dezember hinaus ergebnisoffen und ohne
vorfestlegung wirklich ohne
vorfestlegung dass es unser erwarten
[Applaus]
sie haben berichtet über eine einigung
über die entlastung ist muss zur
abfederung der
gestiegenen preise mehr geben als bisher
verändert würde sie haben über die mir
jetzt diskutiert wir werden die
bewährten es muss mehr gemacht werden um
die hohen belastung von bürgern und
betrieben abzufedern wenn sie gute
vorschläge machen werden wir sie
unterstützen wir haben unsere eigenen
vorschläge eingebracht die sie nicht so
bürokratisch für das was bei ihnen
diskutiert wird die wirken sofort an
zielgenau das wäre die basis auch hier
zusammenzukommen und letzte bemerkung
wenn sie so vorgehen dann kann gelingen
dass wir so wie wir der sondersitzung
vor vier wochen über die grenzen von
regierung und opposition zu einem
breiteren konsens zusammen kommen und
mein fester eindruck ist in dieser lage
in der reha sind wird es unserem land
gut tun in der
kreation sprecher für klimaschutz und
energie in der unionsfraktion gilt auch
als einer der profiliertesten politiker
in diesem sektor in der union und er hat
hier deutliche unterstützung signale
richtung robert habeck richtung
bundeswirtschaftsminister gesandt in
sachen ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
wasserstoff und effizienz fordert aber
auch eine ergebnisoffene prüfung der
laufzeitverlängerung für atomkraftwerke
an dreas forderung dass kranke junge aus
der spd fraktion ist da
die mir putins gegen die ukraine mit all
den konsequenzen auch für uns in den
zeiten in denen wir immer noch die
folgen der korona pandemie zu bewältigen
haben und in der zeit der
generationenübergreifenden
existenziellen zukunftsaufgaben braucht
es einen staat der stabilität schafft
und handlungsfähigkeit bewahrt und der
jung genau das verkörpert unser haushalt
dem wir hier in dieser woche diskutieren
und auch genau das verkörpert der
einzelplan vom bundeswirtschaftsminister
den wir hier heute diskutieren denn mit
dem stellen wir
nicht nur die notwendigen mittel bereit
wenn die äußere innere und auch die
soziale sicherheit für unsere
bürgerinnen und bürger zu gewährleisten
mit diesem haushalt eröffnen wir auch
ein jahrzehnt der investition in noch
nie dagewesener höhe in klimaschutz und
in die zukunftsfähigkeit unseres landes
zusammen mit den entsprechenden
bereichen aus dem energie und klimafonds
arbeit hat es erwähnt sind es etwa elf
milliarden euro die der ansatz mit sich
bringt und die investieren wir in
transformationsprozesse der wirtschaft
und wir unterstützen damit auch das
nachhaltige wirtschaftswachstum und die
auswirkungen der korona pandemie also
auch wirklich vollständig hinter uns zu
lassen ich finde dabei überaus
erfreulich dass der einzelplan 09 der
bis jetzt vorliegt im vergleich zum
ersten festgestellten ansatz um 1,8
milliarden euro angewachsen ist allein
das ist für mich ein signal wie
bedeutend und wichtig die aufgabe ist
und wie ernst die bundesregierung diese
herausforderung nimmt
wir werden
wir werden mit diesen mitteln also
innenbereiche neue mobilität
digitalisierung die weiterentwicklung
der wasserstoffwirtschaft investieren
genauso wie wir innovationsförderung
vornehmen werden hilfe bei
unternehmensgründungen leisten werden
die von kohle ausstieg betroffenen
regionen unterstützen werden und vor
allen dingen auch die strukturschwäche
die wir im land auch immer noch haben
bekämpfen werden außerdem sichere mir
damit es wurde erwähnt die gasversorgung
in dem wir ausländische bezugsquellen
diversifizieren und mit massiven
investitionen auch unsere wirtschaft im
land darauf vorbereiten lng terminals
und energie umzusetzen und auch zu
nutzen vor allem werden wir aber den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
forcieren und das will ich auch noch mal
ganz klar unterstreichen denn wenn uns
das gelingt uns von fossilen
energieträger und unabhängig zu machen
entziehen wir uns auch dieser
verheerenden preissteigerungen spirale
unter der wir gegenwärtig alle leiden
und deshalb ist das eine eine aufgabe
mit existenzieller bedeutung auch für
die zukünftigen generationen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
neben diesen massiven investitionen im
etf ich nenne hier nochmal die 1,2
milliarden euro für die industrie zur
dekarbonisierung ich nenne ich ja auch
noch mal die 1,4 milliarden euro für die
schaffung von lade- und elektro
infrastruktur
ich nenne aber auch die zehn milliarden
euro für die energetische
gebäudesanierung
richtet sich der fokus dieses haushaltes
insbesondere aber auch auf den
innovativen mittelstand zu stärken
wollen und mit dem wir durch gezielte
fördermaßnahmen mehr wachstumsimpulse
versetzen wollen um innovation und
beschäftigung zu schaffen ich will ja
exemplarisch nennen dass wir mit etwa
drei milliarden euro in forschung und
entwicklung investieren wir stellen über
eine milliarde euro für die
digitalisierung in diesem bereich zur
verfügung im übrigen ein ansatz der sich
im vergleich zum letzten verdoppelt hat
und diesen ansatz flankieren wird dann
auch noch mal mit 2,7 milliarden euro
aus dem egf ich glaube das sind gut
investierte gelder um unsere wirtschaft
auch im digitalen bereich
zukunftsfähiger zu machen und darüber
hinaus erwähne ich auch ein neues
programm in höhe von zehn millionen euro
indem wir gemeinwohlorientierte camos
unterstützen ein bereich den es so
vorher noch gar nicht gegeben hat
schließlich lernen dass wir mit blick
auf die
verstetigte haushaltsplan größe der grw
eine wichtige größe haben im rahmen der
strukturschwäche anzusetzen so wie wir
es in den letzten vergangenen
jahrzehnten auch getan haben und vor dem
hintergrund leistet auch die grw hier
wieder unverzichtbare möglichkeiten für
die bekämpfung der strukturschwäche und
die angleichung der lebensverhältnisse
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und der
junge ich nehme da ihr angebot auch
gerne freund freudvoll zur kenntnis mit
dem vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf haben
wir jetzt schon gute möglichkeiten die
weichen in richtung transformation
unserer wirtschaft und zukunftsfähigkeit
unseres landes zu stellen ich glaube
aber dass kein entwurf nicht so gut ist
dass er nicht noch verbessert werden
könnte und dem hall und dem
parlamentarischen verfahren die war
andreas mattfeldt liebe andere
haushälter wollen wir uns den prozess
gerne stellen ich bin gespannt auf
unsere zusammenarbeit und ich freue mich
darauf vielen dank
frank junge ist für die spd im
haushaltsausschuss und betreut da in den
einzelplan 09 wirtschaft und klimaschutz
und dem sc in dieser debatte gerade geht
und falls sie ein paar mal gestolpert
sind sowie die abkürzung ek ist
eigentlich gar nicht so schwer es geht
um den energie und klimafonds
das sind bekanntlich 200 milliarden euro
die bis 20 26 ausgegeben werden sollen
wolfgang wille ist der nächste redner
für die af die fraktion auch er mitglied
im haushaltsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen die regierung
muss alles tun um die heutigen krisen in
schranken zu halten
die auswirkungen auf die bürger wie auch
die wirtschaft zu begrenzen das
gegenteil wird jedoch gemacht und ihr
ministerium herr kollege habeck spielt
hier eine unrühmliche rolle
die etablierte politik leidet unter
einer dramatischen selbstüberschätzung
unter einer überschätzung der
möglichkeiten die dieses land hat aber
auch europa und die westliche welt das
gefährdet unser land unsere bürger und
unsere wirtschaft die die nicht so viel
haben spüren es zuerst und die die
weiterdenken sagen es zuerst
die harte locker und politik in der
krise hat viele existenzen zerstört und
die staatsverschuldung gewaltig
ansteigen lassen machtpolitische
übertreibungen ich werde nur den namen
söder kosten mehr als wir uns leisten
können
jetzt hat auf den angriffskrieg in der
ukraine mit hektischen sanktionen zu
reagieren die uns mehr schaden als der
russischen regierung die sich nun
stärker china und indien zuwendet auch
das zeigt eine überschätzung dessen was
unser land aushält wir erleben es jeden
tag an den zapfsäulen
es beweist selbst erzeugte not wenn und
sie herr minister weg nach katar pilgern
um dort um gaslieferungen nach zu suchen
die dortigen regenten sind genauso wenig
lupenreine demokraten wie herr putin
deutsche regierung verschärfen diese
krisen und sie setzen ihre ideologische
klimapolitik noch obendrauf
europa glaubt hier den oberlehrer für
die ganze welt spielen zu können während
china weiter kohlekraftwerke baut die
deutsche politik stock besessen die
brüsseler vorgaben vorgaben regelmäßig
noch weiter auf
sie von der ampel aber auch ihre
schwarzen sekundanten riskieren den
industriestandort deutschland
millionen von arbeitsplätzen und den
letzten rest noch verbliebener solidität
der staatsfinanzen
es ist krasse selbstüberschätzung
wenn man auf dem weltmarkt der erste
sein will er das epochale hochrisiko
projekt der großen transformation
durchziehen will
[Applaus]
wachsende summen werden in wasserstoff
strategien in anderen weltregionen wie
nordafrika gesteckt die risiken für die
energieversorgung steigen dadurch weiter
solche beträge sind im haushalt an
mehreren stellen versteckt nicht zuletzt
im sogenannten energie und klimafonds
dieser etf wurde gerade durch den
zweiten nachtragshaushalt 20 21 mit 60
milliarden euro neuen schulden
aufgefüllt vergessen sie nicht auch das
geld müssen die konsumenten und
steuerzahler mühsam erarbeiten
während der transparenz ist auch bei
vielen förderprogrammen zu beklagen
beispielsweise bei zimmer- und gr winken
geradezu das gegenteil von transparenz
beweist das ministerium bei der
förderung effizienter gebäude der
knallharte förderstopp vom 24 januar hat
bei vielen bauherren das vertrauen
zerstört
wie die bundesregierung so auf 400.000
neue wohnungen im jahr kommen will
bleibt ihr geheimnis
die fw fraktion wird immer transparenz
verlangen vor der selbstüberschätzung
der etablierten politik warnen und die
interessen der bürger im auge behalten
die keine experimente sich leisten
können und auch nicht wollen
[Applaus]
der bundestag diskutiert über den
einzelplan 09 so heißt das und er in dem
geht es um wirtschaft und klimaschutz
zuständiger minister ist bekanntermaßen
robert habeck von bündnis 90/die grünen
im moment ist hier die stunde der
haushälter also die haushaltspolitiker
mitglieder im haushaltsausschuss die
sich äußern zum die zu diesem etat die
fachpolitiker umwelt klimaschutz
politiker werden zwar andreas jung am
anfang schon gesehen die kommen aber vor
allem später in dieser debatte jetzt
karsten klein für die fdp-fraktion
auswirkungen das völkerrechtswidrigen
krieg von vladimir putin in der ukraine
und der damit einhergehenden sanktions
natürlich auch in deutschland zu spüren
das spiegelt auch die ifo
konjunkturprognose von gestern wieder
die stadt von einem wachstum von 3,7
prozent
nur noch mit 3,1 prozent und in der
anderen die alternativ szenarien auch
nur noch mit 2,2 prozent von davon
ausgeht diese wirtschaftlichen
verwerfungen führen natürlich auch zu
preissteigerungen all das belastungen
die natürlich bei unseren bürgerinnen
und bürgern bei sozial schwachen bei den
arbeitsplätzen bei den unternehmen
ankommen die vor allem natürlich auch
die ende energieintensive branche
treffen die logistikbranche die
achillesferse unserer wirtschaft und
deshalb liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ist es richtig gewesen dass sich die
bundesregierung dass ich die
koalitionsfraktionen von spd grüne und
fdp schon auf ein erstes
entlastungspaket vor einigen wochen
geeinigt haben den heizkostenzuschuss in
kronach zum schuss den sofort zuschlag
für von armut betroffene kinder den
arbeitnehmer pauschbetrag angehoben
haben um die pendlerpauschale
das waren wichtige zeichen schulamt in
dieser krise dass wir handlungsfähig
sind dass wir auch schon antizipieren
was sich in den nächsten wochen
entwickeln kann und genauso richtig ist
dass liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dass diese bundesregierung einen
ergänzungs haushalt angekündigt hat
einen haushalt der abbilden soll was
aufgrund der ukraine krise noch auf uns
zukommen wir was wir jetzt noch gar
nicht voll umfänglich abschätzen können
auch das zeigt handlungsfähigkeit und
transparenz
und dass wir im zuge dieses ergänzungs
haushalts natürlich auch darüber
sprechen müssen wie die bürgerinnen und
bürger die unternehmen wie gesagt die
logistikbranche die für uns so wichtig
ist aber auch die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer die jeden morgen mit ihrem
auto in die arbeitsstätte fahren und den
wohlstand erwirtschaften die
steuergelder wirtschaften die wir hier
so gern verteilt deshalb ist es wichtig
dass wir natürlich auch über deren
entlastungen jetzt in den nächsten tagen
sprechen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich finde
es ist ein kraftvolles zeichen wenn im
anbetracht der korona krise und das
ukraine kriegs diese koalition die jetzt
gerade mal 100 tage im amt ist ein
zweites entlastungspaket heute nacht
verabredet hat das in wenigen minuten
verkündet wird das zeigt wir sind
handlungsfähig in so einer extremen
krisensituation und
sehr der minister habe sie haben
natürlich auch bei diesem ergänzungs
haushalt bei auch bei den
haushaltsplanungen jetzt die
unterstützung der freien demokraten wenn
es darum geht dass wir bei der
abhängigkeit von fossilen energieträgern
weiterkommen das wird von den fossilen
energieträgern weg kommen wie wir es
auch vereinbart haben und sie ist aber
auch wichtig dass wir dazu natürlich wie
wir es für ander tagen macht
wirtschaftlich instrumente nutzen und
ich fand ihre aussagen zum thema
subventionen ja da wirklich sehr
treffend aber dass wir auch dafür sorgen
dass die instrumente die im einzelplan
09 chf stehen auch zielgerichtet und
wirkungsorientierte eingesetzt werden es
geht darum wie viel co2 einsparung
können wir dann mit diesen mitteln auch
erzielen den letzten der letzten
legislaturperiode gab es mehrere
bundesrechnungshof berichte die
festgestellt haben dass eben diese
wirkungszusammenhänge nicht ordentlich
funktioniert haben dass das steuerungs
management nicht ordentlich funktioniert
hat und deshalb wollen wir uns gemeinsam
auf den weg machen an der stelle
nachzubessern
denn wir wollen dass die steuermittel
auch zu einem wirkungsvollen ergebnis
führen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der ukraine krieg hat natürlich auch
noch zu einer ganzen reihe von anderen
aufgaben in den einzeln lagen 9 und beim
aufgabenfeld des wirtschaftsministeriums
geführt ich will drei kurz noch am ende
meiner rede ansprechen das erste ist das
thema rüstungsexport kontrolle es muss
jedem klar sein dass wir mit unserer
bundeswehr mit den verteidigen mit der
verteidigungsindustrie einen beitrag
leisten zum nachhaltigkeits ziel der
vereinten nationen zur sicherung von
frieden und das muss natürlich auch bei
der rüstungsexport kontrolle die jetzt
neu aufgestellt wird berücksichtigt
werden den zweiten punkt den ich
ansprechen möchte ist dass freihandel
freihandel hat sich nicht überlebt ganz
im gegenteil es ist in dieser situation
umso wichtiger dass wir uns zum
freihandel mit unseren partnern die
gleiche werte vertreten vereinbaren
und der dritte punkt den ich noch kurz
an sprechen möchte ist das thema
raumfahrt ein großer haushaltsposten
herr minister in ihrem einzel plan und
da haben wir große aufgaben es war
richtig dass wir über alle
berichterstatter lieber kollege
mattfeldt hinweg uns immer zum ariane
programm zu unabhängigen zugang zum
weltall bekannt haben das war eine
richtige entscheidung die noch mal
deutlicher wird in diesen tagen deshalb
müssen wir gemeinsam die esa konferenz
im herbst auch vorbereiten hier in
diesem haus auch mitgestalten weil er
geht es wirklich um die zukunft unserer
nation vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
karsten klein ist für die heftig die im
haushaltsausschuss des bundestages dass
wir so einen beitrag zur debatte über
den etat wirtschaft und klimaschutz und
der hat schon angesprochen die
zehnstündigen beratungen des
koalitionsausschusses
der erste morgen
zu ende gegangen ist und noch eine
kleine information für sie in gut
anderthalb stunden soll es eine
pressekonferenz zu den ergebnissen geben
zentrale frage wie kommen bürgerinnen
und bürger den an das geld das ihnen der
staat zur entlastung zukommen lassen so
interessante fragen die uns da erwarten
antworten ab 11 dem natürlich live in
jetzt victor perli auch er ist mitglied
im haushaltsausschuss und mitglied der
fraktion die linke nicht und sie machen
jetzt fossile energie deals mit katar
und den arabischen emiraten der einst
profi durch den anderen despoten ersetzt
da gibt es nichts schönzureden
die haben sich am blutigen jemand krieg
beteiligt die missachtung elementarer
menschenrechte vor sieben monaten haben
die grünen noch gefordert die fußball wm
in katar abzusagen weil dieses land eine
zu große nähe zu den taliban haben mit
diesem land gehen sie nun herr minister
wie sie selbst sagen großartiger weise
eine langfristige partnerschaft ein
dabei müssen wir weg von solchen
partnerschaften das bedeutet jetzt noch
viele mehr zu investieren in erneuerbare
energien und die klimafreundliche
transformation der gesellschaft und der
wirtschaft aber genau das macht dieser
haushalt nicht und das findet die linke
völlig falsch
die koalition behauptet dass sie sich
auf 1 200 milliarden euro klima paket
geeinigt haben für die nächsten fünf
jahre das handelsblatt nennt das völlig
zurecht plumpes marketing und eine
luftnummer die zwei milliarden sind zum
allergrößten teil ausgaben die schon
längst schon von der alten regierung
eingeplant worden sind zudem sind sich
eines investitionen fürs klima ein
viertel entfällt auf die streichung der
eeg umlage
hier übernimmt der staat was vorher die
stromzähler bezahlt haben das ist
natürlich richtig aber es ist eben kein
neuer cent für klimaschutz
viele menschen leiden unter den
steigenden energiepreisen die regierung
muss viel massiver gegen steuern die
entlastungs paket
ist ein köpfchen das bereits durch die
hohen preise und durch die steigenden
krankenkassenbeiträgen die helaba heute
verkündet hat aufgefressen wird es
reicht überhaupt nicht eine warme
wohnung darf kein luxusgut werden
wir müssen arbeitnehmer arme menschen
und die mittelschichten unterstützen zum
beispiel durch denselben punkt der
mehrwertsteuer auf energie zum beispiel
durch energie geld durch basistarife
beim strom durch eine erhöhung von hartz
4 und der grundsicherung
in diesen wochen zogen die
energiekonzerne besonders ab die
sicherheit sich extra profite die nutzen
diesen schlimmen krieg aus um besonders
starke preise zum beispiel beim sprit zu
erheben wir finden es ist sinnvoll dass
man hier in einer sondersteuer diese
extraprofite abschöpfen und es ist
spannend dass jetzt auch
nobelpreisträger joseph stiglitz genau
das vor steckt wir sind sehr
interessiert interessiert ob sie das
aufgreifen werden es wäre sozial gerecht
meine damen und herren es
ist auch höchste zeit dass bei den
strombörsen endlich die preise begrenzt
werden meine damen und herren die
bittere wahrheit ist dass diese
bundesregierung mehr als doppelt so viel
für rüstung ausgeben möchte in den
nächsten fünf jahren wie fürs klima wir
finden das muss dringend korrigiert
werden dazu werden wir als linke die aus
dass beratung nutzen ich freue mich auf
die beratung in vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen felix spanischer
präsidenten herr minister liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wirtschaft wirtschaft wirtschaft diese
worte haben für mich seit der letzten
woche einen anderen klang denn es waren
diese worte mit denen wolodimir selensky
die gesamte deutsche politik
gewissermaßen uns alle ja so deutlich
kritisiert hat mich hat das nachdenklich
gemacht und ich finde er hat recht wir
haben uns in der vergangenheit
aus durchaus nachvollziehbaren
ökonomischen gründen und motiven
geopolitisch falsche falsch entschieden
wir wären heute souveräner in bezug auf
importstopps etwa wenn wir uns weniger
abhängig gemacht hätten von
fossilen rohstoffen aus russland
bisschen der minister jetzt angesprochen
zum verkauf von gasspeichern an gazprom
da kommen wir gleich noch zu
meine damen und herren wer diese
zusammenhänge angesprochen hat und etwa
19 21 frage gestellt hat wurde in der
vergangenheit belächelt oder belehrt das
wäre ja ein rein privatwirtschaftliches
projekt wenn wir also jetzt über diese
zeitenwende bei dir so viel gesprochen
wird sprechen dann darf das keine allein
verteidigungspolitische sein es muss
auch eine energiepolitische zeitenwende
sein denn
jedes windrad
jedes windrad das wir aufstellen sichert
unser klima schützt unser klima und
schützt unsere freiheit und mit jedem
solarpanel dass wir montieren werden wir
unabhängiger von kohle gas und
diktatoren
meine damen und herren die
der völkerrechtswidrige angriffskrieg in
die ukraine hat auch massive
auswirkungen auf die deutsche wirtschaft
die hohen energiepreise bedrohen gerade
die energieintensive industrie
lieferketten brechen ein produktion geht
zurück die eu hat gestern einen ball für
rahmen beschlossen und in dem werden wir
jetzt in den nächsten wochen und mit dem
ergänzungs haushalt dafür sorgen die
unternehmen zu unterstützen sie es
brauchen aber meine damen und herren
diese ganzen effekte treffen ja nicht
alle unternehmen aber insbesondere
auch die die sich eigentlich gerade auf
dem weg in die transformation zur
klimaneutralität gemacht haben und die
jetzt mit ihren belegschaften von großen
unsicherheiten bestehen unsicherheiten
ob diese transformation noch gelingen
kann oder es ums große bloße überleben
geht und meine damen und herren
in einer situation in der sich die
ökologischen krisen einerseits und der
ökonomischen derart zuspitzen
gleichzeitig und denn der eine kluge
transformation beide krisen adressiert
muss ein bundeshaushalt antworten auf
diese unsicherheiten und herausforderung
geben und so weit das jetzt möglich ist
tut es diese haushaltsentwurf
ich will ihnen das an einem beispiel das
stellvertretend für viele deutlich
machen in duisburg der stadt aus der ich
komme und die ich hier vertreten darf
diese stadt ist überregional bekannt als
stadt von kohle und stahl die kohle geht
jetzt schritt für schritt und das ist
richtig aber der stahl der soll bleiben
und er soll grünen werden drei prozent
der deutschen co2 emissionen 3 prozent
entstehen allein am standort von
thyssenkrupp steel in duisburg 3 prozent
an einem standort dass das zehnfache des
gesamten innerdeutschen flugverkehr ist
gleichzeitig 17.000 arbeitsplätze gut
bezahlte arbeitsplätze auf diesem einen
standort auf einem werksgelände fünfmal
so groß wie monaco diese zahlen machen
deutlich wie groß die herausforderung
ist aber die sachen auch deutlich die
riesig der hebel ist wenn uns diese
transformation gelingt ökologisch den
klimaschutz soziale und ökonomische gute
arbeitsplätze und deswegen geben wir in
den nächsten jahren 14 milliarden euro
für den umbau der industrie aus für
klimaschutz differenzbeträge kamen
konfekt for difference wir fördern eine
wasserstoff-infrastruktur im
industriemaßstab
verdoppeln die ausbau kapazitäten für
elektrolyse anlagen schaffen eine
wasserstoff außenwirtschaft wie sie sie
noch nie gab all das tun wir damit die
unternehmen die jetzt diese unsicherheit
haben sicherheit für ihre investitionen
haben die jetzt anstehen und wir
und wir sorgen dafür dass die emissionen
im energiebereich im gebäudebereich
zurückgehen und gehen weg vom prinzip
der vorgänger-regierung staatlich zu
fördern was eh schon state of the art
ist hin zum prinzip maximaler co2
einsparung pro euro den der staat zahlt
das ist kluge politik und wir haben noch
viel anderes vor aber die grundlage von
allem meine damen und herren ist der
massive der beschleunigte der
ambitionierte und flächendeckende ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien und herr jung
ich habe mich sehr gefreut über das was
wir gesagt haben die unterstützung
vielleicht telefonieren sie mal mit
hendrik wüst oder markus söder denn wenn
wir diesen ausbau wollen dann müssen
wünsch ausbau blockade gesetze wie 1000
meter in nrw und zehnmal in bayern
endlich der vergangenheit an es ist doch
absurd das sieht landesregierung die
cdu-geführte landesregierung nrw morgens
im letzten jahr sagt wir wollen fünf
jahre früher klimaneutralen am gleichen
nachmittag 1000 meter abstand für
windräder gegenüber der wohnbebauung
beschließt das blockiert den ausbau
damit gewinnt man vielleicht waren aber
nicht die zukunft wir wollen die zukunft
gewinnen dieser haushalt ist eine gute
grundlage wir werden weiterarbeiten
vielen dank ich freue mich drauf
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
hansjörg durz
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen meine damen und herren
nichts weniger als eine zeitenwende
erleben wir seit dem 24 februar übrigens
exakt seit einem monat
nur in diesem haushaltsentwurf ist diese
zeitenwende nicht angekommen
wir sprechen ja jetzt schon von einem
ergänzungs haushalt
dieser haushaltsentwurf ist noch geprägt
von der vorgänger krise also von der
korona krise und übrigens auch von der
vorgängerregierung
die grundpfeiler dieses wirtschafts
haushaltes tragen nach wie vor die
handschrift von peter altmaier
kernelemente dieses einzel planes kann
man auch deshalb übrigens gut
unterstützen
das gilt sowohl für die deutliche
steigerung der ausgaben im bereich der
digitalen agenda wo weitgehend bisherige
projekte fortgeführt werden als auch für
die höheren ausgaben im bereich der
luft- und raumfahrt geld fließt sind
viele projekte die von der union aufs
gleis gesetzt wurden es gilt für den
aufbau einer souveränen cloud-dienst
infrastruktur garics oder bei maßnahmen
zur innovationsförderung stichwort
agentur für sprung innovationen schön
dass auch ein grüner wirtschaftsminister
die prestige projekte seines schwarzen
vorgängers fort führt die ideen scheinen
offensichtlich gar nicht so ganz
schlecht gewesen zu sein
doch in den in den tiefen dieses
haushaltes finden sie natürlich auch
klassisch grüne themen diese zwei
milliarden mehr sind bereits
angesprochen worden die ausgangs kapitel
ausgaben kapitel die davon am meisten
profitieren sind die bereiche
klimaschutz energie und nachhaltigkeit
darin finden sich projekte wie die
unterstützung von real laboren oder von
klimaschutz kampagnen ich stelle mir
aber die frage wie wollen sie die ganzen
förderprojekte und sie haben vorher ja
eine ganze reihe von förderprojekten
aufgezählt wie wollen sie die alle
administrieren wenn sie das bundesamt
für wirtschaft und ausfuhrkontrolle
nicht ausreichend mit stellen ausstatten
und ich stelle mir zum zweiten die frage
wo bleiben denn jene die die
energiewende am ende in unserem land
umsetzen wer installierten wärmepumpen
in den häusern wer schreibt denn die
solaranlagen auf unsere dächer herbig
ist ausgerechnet der mittelstand der in
diesem haushaltsentwurf der große
verlierer ist im haushalts- kapitel
mittelstand
kürzen sie 200 millionen euro heraus das
ist das völlig falsche signal an die
menschen und unternehmen die die
energiewende in unserem land umsetzen
doch die unternehmen wollen nicht nur
unterstützung etwa für forschung und
entwicklung sie wollen von ihrem
wirtschaftsminister vor allem hören ob
die zeitenwende die in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik angekommen ist auch
eine zeitenwende in der
wirtschaftspolitik ist davon ist in
diesem haushalt nämlich bisher nicht
viel zu sehen angenommene werte für
inflations- und wachstumszahlen sind
längst überholt ist gar kein vorwurf
sondern ist schlicht fakt und in diesem
sich eintrübenden wirtschaftlichen
umfeld erwarten unternehmen zunächst
einmal eines dass sich der
wirtschaftsminister dafür einsetzt dass
sie nicht noch mit zusätzlichen
belastungen
traktiert werden ihr kollege christian
lindner forderte am dienstag hier alles
vermeiden was menschen und betriebe
weiter belasten könnte herr habeck
springen sie über ihren schatten sagen
sie ja zu einem belastungsmoratorium und
wenn sie schon nicht auf uns hören dann
doch zumindest auf ihren finanzminister
zudem hätten die unternehmen die
besonders an dem sein unter dem
sanktions regime leidend jetzt wirklich
gerne gewusst wie die von ihnen
versprochenen schutz maßnahmen aussehen
doch während die merkel-regierung es
schafft er in weniger als drei wochen
nach den corona ausbrüchen von heinsberg
erste konkrete unterstützungsmaßnahmen
vorzustellen gelingt ihnen das mit einem
kleineren hilfspaket bisher nicht wo
sind denn diese maßnahmen
in den vergangenen wochen
mussten wir alle lernen dass viele
frühere überzeugungen durch den
russischen angriffskrieg obsolet
geworden sind dazu gehört die annahme
russland mit wirtschaftlichen
abhängigkeiten einbinden zu können wir
begrüßen es deshalb dass sie sicher habe
ich derzeit redlich bemühen alternative
quellen für gas und öl in der welt auch
zu tun um die energieversorgung in
unserem land sicherzustellen
ich habe übrigens respekt davor haben
denn ich bin mir sicher dass ihnen das
auch nicht leicht fällt denn bei ihren
gesprächen mit den scheichs beugen sie
sich nicht nur den realitäten
sondern mit sicherheit platzen
gleichzeitig auch grüne träume
natürlich sind
energielieferungen natürlich sind
energielieferungen aus diesen ländern
eine alternative eine energiepolitische
strategie die wir übrigens noch nicht
sehen darf aber das ist ihnen auch klar
nicht bloß vom 2 zum streichen sie muss
gerade jetzt
technologieoffen und ohne denkverbote
alle möglichkeiten übrigens auch alle
möglichkeiten in unserem land in den
blick nehmen und fehler der
vergangenheit vermeiden denn wir wollen
alle
schließlich wir wollen alle schließlich
diversifizieren also uns breiter
aufstellen und deutschland darf sich
energiepolitisch nie wieder in eine
solche abhängigkeit begeben stattdessen
bekommen wir dieser tage deutlich vor
augen geführt wie wichtig es ist
gleichgesinnte partner an der seite zu
fragen und deshalb gilt es jetzt zu
ratifizieren auch dazu gibt es ein
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichtes
grafik zu einer zeitenwende in der
wirtschaftspolitik gehört auch engere
zusammenarbeit mit demokratien ebenen
sie jetzt ca der zusammenarbeit mit
kanada den weg wenn nicht mit kanada mit
wem denn dann und wenn nicht jetzt wann
dann und zwar nicht nur aus ökonomischen
gründen sondern auch als klares signal
an die autokraten dieser welt vielen
dank
mit hans jörg butt sind die
fachpolitiker ans pult zurückgekehrt in
der debatte über den einzelplan
wirtschaft und klimaschutz für den
bundeshaushalt
2022 das werden sie auch bei den
folgenden redner rinnen bemerken verena
huber zum beispiel ist die nächste
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
spd-fraktion und da zuständig unter
anderem für den bereich wirtschaft und
zwar anders als wir es uns erhofft haben
anders als wir gedacht haben dass
bewohner noch nicht vorbei
und schlimmer als wir befürchtet haben
herrscht ein krieg in der mitte unseres
kontinents und das ist eine katastrophe
für die menschen in der ukraine
wer aber darauf wartet dass alles wieder
so wird wie es einmal war wird
vergeblich warten müssen
wir sehen die wirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen dieses kriegs höhere
energiekosten
unterbrochenen lieferketten verlust von
handelspartnern und es zeigt auch die
bestehenden schwächen unserer wirtschaft
der letzten jahrzehnte unsere starke
abhängigkeit von rohstofflieferungen aus
einzelnen ländern aber auch von fossilen
energieträgern
wird jetzt aber alles immer schlechter
und da sage ich ganz klar nein ich bin
überzeugt deutschland bleibt auch die
stärkste wirtschaft auf diesem kontinent
in europa
und wir bleiben soziale marktwirtschaft
aber wir werden sie weiter entwickeln
hin zu einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft
die auf erneuerbare energien setzt
ressourcen effizient verwendet und
nachhaltig arbeitet und dafür müssen wir
einiges ändern ja und das wollen
vielleicht manche nicht in diesem land
aber wir schonen damit die wirtschaft
stabil bleibt haben wir maßnahmen
eingeleitet um die direkten folgen die
wirtschaftlichen folgen des krieges
abzufedern wir werden nachher noch ein
entlastungspaket vorstellen aber
das wird nicht reichen
wir müssen auch an die wurzel des
problems und langfristig agieren wir
brauchen nachhaltiges wachstum das
bedeutet dass wir nicht überall geld
drauf werfen und fördern was da ist
sondern das was in der zukunft wachsen
kann und mit dem klima und
transformations- fonds machen wir das
200 milliarden sind dort drin und damit
werden wir ein nachhaltiges instrument
schaffen für diesen wandel
bei allem wandel 1 wollen wir bleiben
und das ist ein bruch
technologiestandort damit das so bleibt
wie es schon waren dass wir auf
innovation setzen und dafür sind über 5
milliarden euro in diesem
wirtschaftsraum halt vorgesehen zu
zukunft gehört aber auch zu schauen wo
müssen wir dennoch gezielt rein
investieren unter anderem in unsere
mikro chip technologie und industrie und
das tun wir mit rund 2,7 milliarden geld
ist das eine wir brauchen aber auch die
leute die anpacken und umsetzen und
deswegen brauchen wir auch 'nen neuen
gründungs geist in diesem land es gibt
viele ideen die zu kleinen und großen
unternehmen führen und wir brauchen vor
allen dingen auch mehr große unternehmen
die aus innovation entstehen und hier
müssen wir die rahmenbedingungen run von
wachstumskapital bis mitarbeitenden
beteiligung ist ein stichwort genannt
und hier liegt auch der haushalt und
unser koalitionsvertrag die grundlage
wir haben viele chancen in diesem land
wir sind chancen land wir müssen die
chancen besser nutzen bei der
einwanderung zum beispiel wir haben eine
starke willkommenskultur in deutschland
aber die bürokratie die steht doch
manchmal im wege wenn es schnell gehen
muss und wir sprechen nämlich deswegen
explizit doch nicht nur von einem
fachkräftemangel sondern es ist ein
kräftemangel uns fehlen die leute
überall um auch diesen wandel
mitzugestalten und deswegen müssen wir
moderner werden wir müssen schneller
werden digitaler in unseren planungs
beschleunigungen und wir brauchen auch
insbesondere für unsere wirtschaft
weniger bürokratie und das packen wir
als starke
querschnittsaufgabe in dieser regierung
an diesen fortschritt steht
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat gestern
sehr gut eines auf den punkt gebracht er
hat gesagt große krisen sind immer auch
ein anstoß für aufbruch und veränderung
in deutschland sind wir gut dinge
weiterzuentwickeln aber wir tun uns
manchmal schwer auch völlig neue wege zu
gehen ja es ist vieles nicht mehr so wie
vorher wie vor corona und vor dem
angriffskrieg eben anders in dieser
neuen zeit
jetzt habe ich in meiner rede viel über
1 gesprochen vielleicht ist dem ein oder
anderen profi tat auch bekannt es ist
nämlich eine zeile aus einem song von
herbert grönemeyer
und ich würde gerne mit einem appell
ebenfalls aus grönemeyers text enden
genug ist zu wenig gehen wir voran
verena hubert stellvertretende
vorsitzende der spd-fraktion endet mit
einem zitat von herbert grönemeyer
und hier geht es weiter
und zum thema wirtschaft und klimaschutz
mit live ire colm aus der afg fraktion
da ist er stellvertretender vorsitzender
sehr geehrte bürger frau präsidentin
meine damen und herren heute morgen habe
ich den fernseher eingeschaltet um mal
zu schauen wie es denn nun wird mit den
energiepreisen es stieg kein weißer
rauch auch heute herr minister kamen
auch kein weißer rauch hier in der
debatte wir müssen also jetzt bis 11 uhr
warten dafür kam aber ein bericht aus
italien in italien liegen die
benzinpreise mittlerweile schon wieder
auf vorkriegsniveau dank einer einfachen
steuersenkung unsere bürger fahren in
belgien tanken fahren in frankreich
tanken in polen tanken weil wir alle
schon was für ihre bürger und
unternehmen getan haben und sie kommen
hier nicht aus dem knick herr minister
seit wochen doktoren sie hier um gelang
es rom gc am tank rabatt mobilitäts geld
steuer lösungen dass es wirklich an
peinlichkeit kaum zu überbieten elf
stunden verhandlung hatte nach elf
stunden für eine ganz einfache sache
schnell und unkompliziert möglich allein
die senkung der energie steuer auf eu
minimum würde das tanken um etwa 30 cent
je liter erträglicher machen das kriegen
wir hier auch da bin ich mir ganz sicher
ganz schnell durch den bundestag also
kommen sie endlich in die pötte
aber vielleicht haben sie es auch gar
nicht so eilig ihn sind die hohen preise
ja sogar ganz recht es geht schließlich
um die große transformation um eine
ideologisch verbohrte energiewende die
vorne und hinten nicht funktioniert und
man sieht an ihrem haushalt dass sie
trotz der aktuellen lage weiter machen
wollen wie bisher sie wollen die
zuschüsse für e autos noch einmal
drastisch erhöhen von 16 auf fünf
milliarden euro
600 millionen wollen sie fürs klima und
der biodiversität im ausland ausgeben
ist das jetzt wirklich wichtig frage ich
sie wenn sie glauben dass sich
deutschland das immer noch leisten kann
dann ist die zeitenwende von der sie
herr minister auch gesprochen haben in
der regierung offensichtlich noch nicht
angekommen
für uns ist klar was zu tun ist wir
müssen schnellstmöglich runter von den
hohen energiepreisen thema inflation
ganz ganz dringend und wir müssen für
energiesicherheit sorgen und das geht
eben ganz sicher nicht mit noch mehr
erneuerbaren energien die machen uns
innig nicht unabhängiger sondern
zusätzlich auch noch wetter abhängig
weil jetzt ist klar wir brauchen einen
gesunden grundlastfähigen energiemix und
dazu gehört auch die kernkraft belgien
hat gerade den geplanten atomausstieg um
zehn jahre verschoben bei uns wird
behauptet das ginge nicht sagt
jedenfalls das zuständige
umweltministerium das ja eine
laufzeitverlängerung geprüft hat im
arbeitgeberverband wird schon von einer
expertin freien prüfung geht es zu recht
wörtlich heißt es in dem bericht auch
weiter der öffentlichkeit wurde
kompetenz vorgetäuscht die smb mv nicht
gibt und der eigene ministerkollege also
sie herr beck wurde die portal ist dies
deswegen weil ein weiterbetrieb von
sechs kernkraftwerken die mit abstand
wirkungsvollste preisgünstigste und am
einfachsten umzusetzende maßnahmen wäre
mit der die versorgungssicherheit für
strom auch umweltfreundlichem wege
maßgeblich erhöht werden könnte zitat
ende exakt das ist das was wir seit
jahren sagen da eine schnelle lösung der
energieprobleme und umweltprobleme haben
möchte der kommt an der kernkraft nicht
vorbei und deshalb ist es zeit herr
minister dass sie dieses thema zur
chefsache machen dass sie es dahin
zurückholen dieses thema hingehört ins
wirtschaftsministerium
handeln sie ansonsten müssen sie sich
wundern dass sie vor den scheichs weiter
tiefpunkten müssen vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion
reinhard houben und reinert oben müsste
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wenn es auch schwer fällt
energiepolitik für anfänger wo kommt
uran her im moment lieferland nummer
eins russland lieferland nummer zwei
cluster peter herold nehmen sie das zur
kenntnis meine damen meine
damen und herren deutschland braucht
einen innovativen wettbewerbsfähigen
mittelstand deswegen sind im
vorliegenden haushalt
innovationsförderung digitalisierung und
die förderung von gründergeist und
selbstständigkeit mit hohen posten
eingeplant ich persönlich möchte aber in
meinen drei minuten auf zwei zahlen
eingeben erste zahl lautet 2,5
milliarden euro
2,5 milliarden euro sind für den bereich
luft- und raumfahrt im haushalt
vorgesehen aber
raumfahrt ist eine entscheidende
grundlage für unser alltägliches
modernes leben maßgebliche
technologische neuerungen gerade im
bereich medizin sind auf raumfahrt
angewiesen und satelliten stellen sicher
unter anderem navigation und vernünftige
wettervorhersagen länder wie frankreich
und italien haben das erkannt sie setzen
ein zeichen und erhöhen ihre mittel
gerade in ihren nationalen programmen
dort gibt es sicherlich möglichkeiten
für die bundesregierung mehr zu
investieren gerade vor dem hintergrund
dass durch die nicht zusammenarbeit mit
russland natürlich wie auch nicht mehr
die fähigkeit haben mit entsprechenden
raketen den raumfahrt betrieb weiter
aufrecht zu halten und eine zweite zahl
sind fünf milliarden euro in unserem
haushalt
5 milliarden für den kauf von
elektroautos und ich stelle die frage
erstens geben die marktpreise nicht eine
zusätzliche
attraktivität des elektroautos her ist
es wirklich so dass wir es ist sinnvoll
die co2 reduzierung auch im verkehr zu
setzen ist es aber sinnvoll hier so viel
geld einzusetzen
denn kann die nachfrage in diesem jahr
überhaupt in der geplanten höhe
befriedigt werden und ich stelle auch in
diesem zusammenhang die frage inwieweit
plug-in-hybride wirklich die eierlegende
wollmilchsau gerade unter den
bedingungen der co2 reduzierung sieht
deswegen
deswegen meine damen und herren
rege ich an dass wir unter den ampel
partnern einmal eruieren ob wir nicht
diesen haushaltsposten
reduzieren und dafür den haushaltsposten
gerade für das nationale
weltraumprogramm erhöhen ich glaube das
ist die richtige zeit dafür es ist
technologischen nötig und wir haben in
deutschland genug know-how genug
industrie gerade auch mittelständische
industrie dieser an dieser stelle
unterstützen sollten vielen dank
sagt reinert ruben und der ist
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion und wir bleiben beim sprechen
für dieses themenfeld und kommen zum
sprecher für energie und klimaschutz der
linksfraktion und das ist ralph lenkert
erwartet schon darauf dass er vor dem
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas
aufgerufen wird die nach einer infektion
jetzt wieder da ist genauso wie
bundestagsvize präsidentin eines ob sie
wird wieder tätig in dieser woche im
parlament
als techniker bin ich es gewohnt im
gesamt prozessen von anfang bis ende zu
denken und das ist auch in der
wirtschaft gerade bei der energie
erforderlich leider macht das bmwf das
nicht ein beispiel durch spekulation
explodierende energiekosten die
glashersteller geraten unverschuldet in
not vielen droht die insolvenz aber ohne
glas gibt es nicht nur keine flaschen es
gibt keine fenster für die energetische
sanierung keine ampullen für medikamente
und auch keine glasfaser verständnis
denn
wenn die glasindustrie in
schwierigkeiten schlittert dann liegt es
auch daran dass diese koalition die
symptome bedeutet statt lösung
anzubieten sie prüfen liquiditätshilfen
das reicht nicht
das genauso unzureichend wie die
unterstützung für menschen mit niedrigen
einkommen
gleichzeitig klettern die erlöse für ehe
und trotz corona von 41 milliarden euro
im jahr 2019 auf 77 milliarden
2021 für rwe im gleichen zeitraum von
13,6 milliarden euro auf 24,8 milliarden
euro und die profite klettern weiter
die linke fordert gegen diese
spekulation vorzugehen wir brauchen eine
preisaufsicht und eine preisfestsetzung
nach herstellkosten
diese extrakte drin müssen dringend
abgeschöpft werden dieses geld benötigen
wir für sozial gerechte energiekosten
für die menschen und für tragbare
energiepreise für die unternehmen auch
für die glasindustrie in thüringen und
franken
kolleginnen und kollegen
nur der ausbau von erneuerbaren energien
schützt uns zukünftig vor preis
explosionen bei erdgas und erdöl jeder
kubikmeter erdgas jeder liter erdöl den
deutschland nicht braucht senkt die
einnahmen von aggressiven autokraten
russland von russland bis arabien gibt
es dann weniger geld zum waffenkauf
zehn milliarden euro mehr für die
energiewende bedeutet mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit bringt mehr für den
klimaschutz und deutlich mehr für die
internationale sicherheit als 100 mio
und für die aufrüstung vielen dank
das lenkrad war das spricht ja für
energie und klimaschutz in der
linksfraktion und mixte rednerin in
dieser ersten beratung des etats für das
ministerium wirtschaft und klimaschutz
wird lisa barth um sein für fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen und sie ist opfer
im ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegin kollegen ja es ist wahr robert
habeck ist grüner und er hat in katar
und auch hier offen gesagt dass
abhängigkeit energien eine schmutzige
kehrseite haben und wenn wir ehrlich
sind wissen wir dass all die jahre das
wir mit unseren geldern von kohle öl und
gas auf gewalt und unterdrückung
finanzieren und gerade weil wir diese
abhängigkeit nicht sofort beenden können
ist es so wichtig dieses dilemma diese
abhängigkeit schonungslos zu beleuchten
so lange bis wir sie endgültig beseitigt
haben einen sehr geehrten damen und
herren
[Applaus]
oder wie der spiegel schrieb die neue
deutsche ehrlichkeit das strategische
staging sie ob ihr es ist grün
denn nur bei uns zu arabischen staaten
hin gewandt haben und das haben sie hier
alle offensichtlich bemerkt heißt das
doch nicht dass wir nicht mit weiteren
ländern 100 prozent erneuerbare klima
partnerschaften richtung grüner
wasserstoff richtung transformation der
wirtschaft anstreben müssen das wollen
wir und das können wir doch meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
die seiner verbündeten wächst auch in
europa der green deal wird aktuell in
brüssel verhandelt und das ist der
schlüssel zu unserer unabhängigkeit von
interessieren dieser schlüssel über
denen wird in brüssel gerade diskutiert
und die eu kann eine gas reduktion
strategie verabschieden effizienz und
erneuerbaren ziele anheben und ehrlich
gesagt ehemalige bremser wie polen an
diesem zeit der zeitenwende vorne mit
dabei die fordern mehr tempo für
erneuerbare denn es ist klar solange wir
die klimakrise und kriege mit
europäischen mit deutschen geldern
finanzieren bleiben wir unfreien bleiben
wir abhängig deswegen setzt freiheit in
der energiepolitik voraus diese in der
verantwortung zu ende zu denken
in jeder einzelentscheidung hinein und
auch vor ort hinein und deswegen werde
ich nicht müde zu wiederholen die 10h
regel in bayern muss abgeschafft werden
lisa warum für die fraktion bündnis 90
die grünen mit einem appell in richtung
und bayern von dort ist ja heute der
appell wiederum gekommen vom
ministerpräsidenten und csu vorsitzenden
markus söder die laufzeit der
atomkraftwerke zu verlängern sonst so
hat er es später ein kalter winter
thomas gebhart ist der nächste redner in
dieser debatte obmann im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie und für die
union zu einer sehr geehrten damen und
herren der krieg den putin gegen die
ukraine führt er wird von tag zu tag
brutaler und dieser krieg macht uns von
tag zu tag
klarer und führt uns vor augen dass es
notwendig wird das wir notwendig im
wahrsten sinne des wortes um die not zu
wenden dass wir so schnell wie möglich
unabhängig werden von diesen importen
von russischen energieträgern von kohle
und öl und gas meine damen und herren
wir müssen so schnell wie möglich
unabhängig werden um diese
kriegsmaschinerie nicht immer weiter zu
finanzieren sei es auch indirekt und wir
müssen unabhängig werden um sicher zu
stellen damit auch im nächsten winter
bei uns die wohnungen nicht kalt werden
und die industrieanlagen die auf gas
angewiesen sind nicht abgeschaltet
werden müssen
meine damen und herren wir
unterstützen die maßnahmen die sinnvoll
sind um diese ziele zu erreichen
es wurde angesprochen wir stimmen morgen
zum beispiel hier im deutschen bundestag
ihren gesetz zu wonach die betreiber von
gasspeichern füllstand vorgaben
einhalten müssen und wir stimmen dem
nicht nur zu wir haben es aktiv
unterstützt wir haben auf die formale
anhörung verzichtet aus einem einzigen
grund damit dieses gesetz schnell in
kraft treten kann damit es auch bereits
in diesem frühjahr und in diesem sommer
seine wirkung entfalten kann und ich
sage ihnen wir werden weiter sinnvolle
maßnahmen an dieser stelle ausdrücklich
unterstützen
aber meine damen und herren
was wir jetzt eben brauchen und zwar
unverzüglich
und das ist ihre aufgabe
herr minister habe ich sie müssen jetzt
unverzüglich alle handlungsoptionen auf
den tisch legen alle handlungsoptionen
etwa die stromerzeugung zumindest aus
den ungehobelten gaskraftwerken
reduzieren und ersetzen die drei kohle
kernkraftwerke länger laufen lassen neue
lieferquellen für gas erschließen dass
sie nur drei optionen von einer ganzen
reihe und all diese option sie müssen
jetzt auf den tisch und sie müssen vor
allem sauber und ehrlich bewertet werden
das ist der entscheidende punkt was
bringen sie was kosten sie wie schnell
können sie überhaupt dazu beitragen das
problem zu lösen und was bedeuten sie
geopolitisch auch etwa für die
menschenrechte und da gehört eben auch
die frage dazu herr minister habeck ist
es wirklich klug um sich aus den armen
von putin zu befreien sich in die arme
des emirs von katar zu werfen ich bin
gespannt was man ihn fünf und zehn
jahren dazu sagen wird
noch ein punkt wir reden über
kurzfristig notwendige maßnahmen es ist
ein muss
dass wir unser ziel
klimaneutral zu werden dabei immer
konsequent mitdenken und das erwarte ich
von einem guten plan dass wir die
kurzfristigen maßnahmen hierzu angehen
dass sie unserem dass sie dem
klimaschutz nicht im wege stehen sondern
dem klimaschutz dienen erneuerbare
energien ausbauen wind und sonnenenergie
erneuerbare kraftstoffe zum beispiel aus
rest- und abfallstoffen und vieles mehr
ein letzter punkt
die steigenden energiepreise
sie werden für immer mehr menschen in
diesem land zu einem immer größer
werdenden problem übrigens auch für
viele unternehmen und
was wir brauchen ist eine effektive
entlastung wir haben dazu vorschläge
gemacht etwa die mehrwertsteuer
reduzieren die energie steuer reduzieren
das waren sind vorschläge die schnell
umzusetzen wären die unbürokratisch
werden und es ist jetzt wirklich ein
gebot der stunde und es ist allerhöchste
zeit dass die regierung so wie andere
europäische regierungen auch an dieser
stelle effektiv handelt
ja
zur wahrheit gehört
diese maßnahmen über die wir reden
kosten den staat geld
aber umso wichtiger genau aus diesem
grund umso wichtiger wäre es dass sie
gerade in einer solchen situation
prioritäten setzen worauf kommt es jetzt
wirklich an worauf kommt es jetzt
wirklich an und sich einfach nur über
beide ohren verschulden die inflation
immer weiter nach oben treiben lassen
das ist eine politik die am ende die
menschen in diesem land ärmer macht und
es macht vor allem diejenigen ärmer die
ohnehin nur wenig haben das ist nicht
der weg in deutschland gehen sollte und
deswegen fangen sie endlich an und
setzen sie prioritäten
herzlich
thomas keppert war das aus der
unionsfraktion obmann im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie noch eine gute
dreiviertelstunde übrigens meine damen
und herren dann gibt's pressekonferenz
der parteivorsitzenden zu dem was hier
die ganze nacht über beraten worden ist
hinsichtlich entlastungen für
bürgerinnen und bürger
das ganze wird hier direkt am
reichstagsgebäude statt finden wir
zeigen ihnen das selbstverständlich live
aber zunächst matthias müller stehen
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der spd
fraktion und
klimaschutz und energie und deswegen
möchte ich im namen der ist für die
bundestagsfraktionen mich bei ihnen herr
minister ausdrücklich bedanken das was
sie in den ersten 100 tagen geleistet
haben war nicht von null auf hundert
sondern es war von 0 auf 200 es sind
herausforderungen gewesen ich glaube ich
selten so groß war und
deswegen möchte ich das ganz bewusst
auch hier meine redezeit nutzen herr
kollege perli von der linkspartei
es ist so schrecklich einfach dann zu
sagen
und jemand vorzuwerfen dann nach katar
zu reisen und herr gib hat es ist so
schrecklich einfach dann zu sagen ob das
richtig war ein
bundeswirtschaftsminister
wer ist verantwortlich dafür zu sagen
wenn ich die konsequenzen dieses
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieges
ziehen will dann muss ich
versorgungssicherheit für diese
wirtschaft und für die bevölkerung in
der bundesrepublik deutschland geld mehr
leisten und dann ist es wohl feiert ihr
diese dinge zu kritisieren
ihnen nehme ich das sogar noch acht
reicht die bunte opposition machen aber
herr kollege geben hat sie las sich
nicht aus der verantwortung und herdorf
in dem zusammenhang auch als roter kann
ich sagen ich versichere ihnen im namen
der spd bundestagsfraktion grüne träume
zerplatzen in diesen vier jahren mit
sicherheit nicht denn
ich bin mir sehr sicher dass das was die
kolleginnen und kollegen mit mir mit
ihnen in der großen koalition erlebt
haben passiert uns mit fdp und grünen
nicht wir wissen
wie wir wissen dass es nur einen
schlüssel zur energie souveränität gibt
und das ist der maximale ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und ich warte darauf dass sie mit uns
vor ort kämpfen wenn sich initiativen
wiedergeben windräder bilden was
natürlich schrecklich einfach es erstmal
gegen diese dinge zu sein nein jetzt
muss doch jedem klar sein es ist im
öffentlichen interesse dass wir mit dem
maximalen ausbau weiter kommt herr
kollege berg
und wenn sie diesen vorwurf machen und
im ried bundesländer gucken in denen sie
politische verantwortung tragen dann
sehen sie dass der ausbau der
erneuerbaren alles andere als
zukunftsgerecht ist deswegen stellen sie
sich hier nicht hin und reden vom
zerplatzen grüner träume liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und was auch in diesem zusammenhang
passt erfahrungen der letzten jahre mit
ihnen ist wenn es dann darum geht wo
sind denn die alternativen ich habe
herrn merz der sondersitzung des
deutschen bundestages am sonntag vor
vier wochen glaube ich gesagt sie haben
keinen inneren kompass denn alleine das
was sie heute wieder geliefert haben das
thema man könnte mal über
laufzeitverlängerung nachdenken ist an
doppelzüngigkeit nicht zu überbieten
herr söder in bayern ganz groß und viel
da vorne weg als jemand der jahrelang
mit der suche eines atomaren endlagers
zu tun hat da kann ich nur sagen es ist
so widersprüchlich und so doppelt fündig
wenn ich jetzt für die
laufzeitverlängerung plädiere aber alles
in den letzten jahren dafür getan haben
dass kein atomares endlager gefunden
wird und schon gar nicht in bayern liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich meine dass die fdk scheinlich sie in
ihren wahlkreisen sofort dazu bereit ist
mag ja sein aber wer in diesen zeiten
atomkraft als zukunftsfähig bezeichnet
dem kann ich nur sagen schauen sie doch
in die ukraine wo sind denn die
gefährdungspotenziale was würden jetzt
gerade in kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen genutzt
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
nein ich bin stolz uns
dass das was wichtig ist in der
zeitenwende
sicherheit zu geben auch für viele die
sorgen haben ob zb energie bezahlbar ist
dass diese ampel koalition auch heute
wieder zeigen wird dass wir die menschen
nicht im stich lassen dass wir
selbstverständlich auch energiekosten
als elementaren bestandteil der
daseinsvorsorge sehen und dass wir aus
jeder krise auch die chancen heraus
machen das ist unsere aufgabe und ich
bin froh dass wir um 11 uhr ein paket
präsentieren das diesen anforderungen
gerecht wird vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
matthias miersch wird das emotionaler in
dieser debatte und in seiner replik auf
den unionsabgeordneten gepard und mit
einem verweis auf die pressekonferenz um
11 und wir können ihn nicht sagen wer
daran teilnehmen nämlich die
vorsitzenden lindner klingbeil und lang
also die drei von fünf
parteivorsitzenden gleich um elf hier am
aus der eingang am reichstagsgebäude
aber erstmal tasten hilfe für die afg
fraktion minister schwören ihre kraft
dem wohle des deutschen volkes widmen
seinen nutzen zu mehren und schaden von
ihm zuwenden leider widmen sich einige
minister weniger dem wohl des deutschen
volkes sondern vorrangig je nachdem
welchen ressorts wie vor stehen dem wohl
verschiedener interessengruppen
finanzspekulanten pharmakonzernen
ausländischen rohstoffen lieferanten
rüstungsfirmen beraterfirmen die die
berater der ministerien beraten und sehr
deutlich den profiteuren der wind und
solar industrie dafür für das geld der
hart arbeitende bevölkerung
verschleudert knapp 28 milliarden euro
sind bereits aus dem energie und
klimafonds
eingepreist ein verantwortungsvoller
gehendes wirtschaftsministerium werde
kurzfristig die abhängigkeit von
stromimporten durch konsequente nutzung
der eigenen ressourcen vor allem der
braunkohle verringern und versuchen
deutschland langfristig unabhängig von
energierohstoffen porten zu machen
[Applaus]
kostengünstige und sicher zur verfügung
stehende energie ist der schlüssel zu
allem zu einer funktionierenden und
erfolgreichen wirtschaft und damit zu
wohlstand für alle statt nun aber genau
darauf hin zu arbeiten gibt diese
bundesregierung zig milliarden euro für
sogenannte erneuerbare energien aus
faktisch handelt es sich um parasitäre
energien da sie niemals allein
funktionieren sondern immer
konventionelle kraftwerke benötigen die
dann einspringen wenn der wind nicht
weht und die sonne nicht scheint mit der
so genannten wasserstoff strategie
begibt sich deutschland wiederum in
abhängigkeit diesmal eben nur andere
länder da die wasserstoffproduktion in
deutschland aufgrund der exorbitanten
energiekosten vollkommen unrentabel ist
der einzige weg deutschland langfristig
weitgehend unabhängig von energie
rohstoffimporten zu machen ist die
erforschung und nutzung der kernenergie
mit sogenannten flüssig brennstoff
reaktoren diese sind da sicher sie
hinterlassen keine hoch radioaktive
reststoffe die in geologischen
zeiträumen gelagert werden müssen sie
verarbeiten die reststoffe der heutigen
kernkraftwerke allein mit denen bei uns
gelagerten hoch radioaktiven reststoffen
könnten wir deutschland mehr als 100
jahre sicher mit strom und andere
energie versorgen und die ausbeute der
energie im verhältnis zur aufgewendeten
energie liegt bei diesen reaktoren
mehrere hundert mal höher als bei den
parasitären energien mit der hohen
prozesswärme können synthetische
kraftstoffe hergestellt werden jedweder
art die kosten für den endverbraucher
liegen weit weit unter denen die sie
heute bezahlen müssen ja es wurde zeit
in anspruch nehmen aber nur ein
bruchteil der parasitären energien
kosten wir könnten uns dann auch die
knapp 24 milliarden euro für die
endlagersuche sparen am ende dieses
weges wäre deutschland weitgehend
unabhängig von jeglichen energie
rohstoffimporten und hätte preiswerte
energie im überfluss
allen hier ohne ideologische
scheuklappen die pragmatische und vor
allem langfristig deutschlands
energieprobleme lösen wollen empfehle
ich unsere broschüre weiter horizont
denken wir nicht denken wir nicht in
legislaturperioden
handeln wir weitsichtig die grüne
energiewende ist gescheitert starten wir
die blaue energiewende entsprechende
haushaltsanträge werden wir
selbstverständlich einreichen vielen
dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die ihren stil sogar
das und hier geht es weiter mit olaf in
der beek klimapolitischer sprecher der
fdp fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
haushaltsfragen sind doch immer
grundsatzfragen wir reden also in dieser
woche nicht nur über die verteilung von
finanziellen mitteln sondern auch über
die politische schwerpunktsetzung für
die nächsten jahre in der ampelkoalition
wird der klimaschutz einen prominenten
teil in der finanzplanung und damit auch
in unserer politik einnehmen wie von
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
angekündigt werden wir bis 20 26 allein
200 milliarden euro für klimaschutz und
transformationen bereitstellen
unser anspruch unser anspruch ist es nun
jeden euro so effizient und so effektiv
wie möglich einzuplanen mit der
gießkanne überall geld zu verteilen ist
weder ökologisch noch ökonomisch
sinnvoll dabei haben wir einiges zu tun
unsere klimapolitik muss vor allem
international verankert werden ein
wichtiger baustein ist dabei der klima
club in dem koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
je mehr partner wir auf der globalen
ebene dazu gewinnen können desto mehr
werden wir auch von unseren
investitionen profitieren können
es ist es ist unser anspruch im globalen
vergleich voranzugehen neben
investitionen im internationalen bereich
müssen wir uns natürlich auch national
der gesamtgesellschaftlichen aufgabe
stellen dabei spielen instrumente wie
das klima geld eine entscheidende rolle
hier arbeitet die ampelkoalition mit
hochdruck an der konkreten ausgestaltung
auch die potenziale die sich für unsere
wirtschaft und dabei insbesondere für
industrie und mittelstand bieten müssen
wir nutzen und als staat die
bestmöglichen rahmenbedingungen dafür
schaffen
technologieoffenheit mut zu innovationen
und die bereitschaft zur transformation
die ampelkoalition liefert german gut
wenn wir
wenn wir zielgenau und nachhaltig
investieren werden wir nicht nur als
volkswirtschaft profitieren sondern
gehen entscheidende schritte in die
nächst auch für die nächsten
generationen auch der herr kollegin
zudem laufe eine zwischenfrage nein auch
in der energiepolitik stehen wichtige
zukunftsinvestitionen an wir haben noch
nie so intensiv wie jetzt über die
energieversorgung in deutschland
diskutiert abhängigkeiten beenden die
diversifizierung unserer
energieversorgung vorantreiben das sind
die drängenden aufgaben der ampel dabei
müssen wir
dabei müssen wir unter anderem
schnellstmöglich lng terminals baum
langfristig werden wir dafür sorgen
deutschland zu energie autark wie
möglich zu machen hier geht es neben dem
massiven ausbau erneuerbarer energien
auch um gezielte
investitionen in die forschung und
entwicklung neuer technologien liebe
kolleginnen kollegen neben allen
schwierigkeiten die uns derzeit
beschäftigen müssen wir im hinblick auf
die klima und energiepolitik aber auch
über chancen reden chance für unsere
wirtschaft chancen für unsere
gesellschaft und auch chancen für die
staatengemeinschaft
klimaschutz kann nur gemeinsam
erfolgreich sein gehen wir mit diesem
haushalt den ersten konsequenten schritt
in die richtige richtung vielen dank
olaf in der billig und wir sind schon
angekommen beim drittletzten redner in
dieser debatte nämlich bei bernd
westphal aus der spd-fraktion
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher und ich
sage es gerne noch mal dann dauert es
nicht mehr lange bis hier der nicht so
tage so anfängt verhandelt wird nämlich
der etat des gesundheitsministeriums
dass wir mit dem mit carlotta wochen wie
es aussieht werden wir das völlig
stressfrei hinkriegen um anschließend
rechtzeitig zu schauen auf die
pressekonferenz der drei koalitionäre zu
entlastungspaket aber jetzt erstmal
bernd lässt dem bundeshaushalt ist immer
auch die stunde des parlaments hier
werden politische ziele und die
maßnahmen mit geld hinterlegt und wir
dürfen eins dabei nicht vergessen wir
haben das den fleißigen
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern den
innovativen und mutigen unternehmer aber
auch vor allen dingen den innovativen
start-ups der industrie und den
mittelstand verdanken die schaffen erst
die voraussetzungen und unseres
politischen spielraum den wir haben
finanziell was zu verteilen
alle wissen dass
der haushalt 2022 unter ganz anderen
wirtschaftlichen rahmenbedingungen
eingebracht wird die ampelkoalition ist
in den ersten 100 tagen enorm gefordert
es sind große themen die wir
gegenüberstehen die wir bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen natürlich nicht
auf dem zettel hatten und die
regierungen der leitung von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz leistet eine
hervorragende arbeit das zeigt sich auch
durch die breite zustimmung in der
bevölkerung
mit einem diner anspruchsvollen politik
auf internationaler ebene mit einer
geschlossenheit und besonderen politik
geben wir orientierung halt und
sicherheit und jetzt kommt es genau
darauf an diesen zusammenhalt zu
organisieren in diesen schwierigen
zeiten in diesen großen
herausforderungen und dann darf man sich
nicht im klein-klein verzettelung
deshalb sage ich ganz deutlich
die rede von friedrich merz gestern
morgen wird dieser verantwortungsvollen
politik nicht gerecht
aus der wirtschaft den unternehmen
erfahren wir hohe zustimmung für die
politik der bundesregierung
jetzt geht es um die schaffung sicherer
verlässlicher rahmenbedingungen für
investitionen
dadurch sichern wir das
wirtschaftswachstum der zukunft und das
heißt nicht unbedingt mehr von dem was
wir jetzt haben sondern wir müssen
besser werden nicht mehr sondern besser
werden bessere autos mit besseren
antrieben bessere energiesysteme bessere
maschinenbau mehr höhere effizienz und
mehr digitalisierung
und klimaschutz
und den klimaschutz werden wir dabei
nicht aus den augen verlieren nur durch
klimaneutrales wirtschaften wird es
gelingen moderne produkte neue
marktperspektiven und vor allen dingen
arbeits und ausbildungsplätze eine
sichere zukunftsperspektive zu geben die
anstrengungen zum erreichen von
klimaneutralität wird die dynamik
zulegen müssen das sichert der haushalt
in der jetzigen form ab und jeder euro
den wir investieren in erneuerbare
energien in den hochlauf der
wasserstoffwirtschaft in eine moderne
infrastruktur wird putin das
kriegshandwerk aus dem hand nehmen das
ist unser ziel mit diesen investitionen
den wir machen
dass deutschland attraktiv ist wie
investitionen
das zeigen die entscheidungen in den
unternehmen in deutschland
so machen sich die stahlindustrie die
chemie die automobilindustrie und andere
auf den weg ihre produktion klimaneutral
zu organisieren und diese transformation
dürfen wir jetzt nicht gefährden aber
auch ausländische investoren wie tesla
north gold oder auch intel zeigen dass
die standortbedingungen in deutschland
optimal sind dass wir mit dieser politik
der bundesregierung einladen sind für
investoren in der welt hier in
deutschland zu investieren und das ist
ein positives und gutes zeichen
meine damen und herren
der angriffskrieg von russland in die
ukraine erfordert natürlich auch
veränderungen der wirtschaftspolitik
unsere maßnahmen die sanktionen zeigen
massiv wirkung in russland das ist die
absicht die treffen gezielt aber haben
natürlich auch auswirkungen auf unsere
unternehmen deshalb sind entlastungen
unterstützung jetzt nicht nur
berechtigterweise für private haushalte
sondern auch für unternehmen
notwendig wichtig und richtig und die
unternehmen brauchen eine stabile brücke
aus diesen krisen modus heraus zu kommen
und wieder fuß fassen zu können und der
haushalt enthält hierfür die richtigen
signale und ich bin davon überzeugt dass
mit einem instrument aus dem ergänzungs
haushalt auch die stabilität und
absicherung erfolgt die europäische
kommission hat hierfür den ball für
rechtlichen rahmen geschaffen den wir
jetzt auch ausnutzen müssen wir haben
die belastungen durch corona noch nicht
hinter uns gelassen wir waren auf einem
guten weg raus in der aus der pandemie
und waren auch auf wachstumskurs und ich
will an dieser stelle noch einmal sagen
wir hätten schon viel weiter sein können
wenn wir endlich eine höhere impfquote
hätten deshalb stimmen sie dem gesetz
zur impfung nicht zur allgemeinen
endlich zu wir brauchen genau diese
rahmenbedingungen liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
die lage ist zu ernst für
parteipolitische spielchen wir dürfen
jetzt die risiken aus inflation aus
geringem wachstum rückgang der kaufkraft
und lieferengpässen auf keinen fall
unterschätzen niemand möchte eine
weitere eskalation des krieges an dieser
stelle danke ich besonders dem
engagement unseres
bundeswirtschaftsministers der wirklich
mit einer sehr anspruchsvoll politik
dafür sorgt unseren wirtschaftsstandort
deutschland zu stabilisieren und auch
für die energieversorgungssicherheit zur
sorge wir in der ampel koalition
organisieren sicherheit im und durch
wandel darauf können sie sich verlassen
der haushaltsentwurf der eingebracht
wurde ist gut wir werden in der
parlamentarischen beratung an der einen
oder anderen stelle ihnen noch besser
machen herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und
das war bernd westphal der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion
drittletzter redner aber ich würde dann
gesagt jetzt andreas mattfeldt
unionsfraktion er ist mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss es könnte also noch
ein bisschen konkret raums geld geben
herr wirtschaftsminister habe
sie sehen mich irritiert
irritiert deshalb war sie ankündigungen
das gestern nacht wichtige
entscheidungen getroffen worden sind und
sie sagen hier im parlament schaut euch
um 11 uhr doch die pressekonferenz ab
herr herbig das geht nicht wenn sie
solche entscheidungen treffen dann
müssen sie wenn sie wir sprechen hier im
haus und parlament anspricht
das ist eine missachtung des parlamentes
das funktioniert für mich um das gehört
sich nicht und
ich darf das auch sagen dass selten nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg
die verantwortung für einen
wirtschaftsraum zu groß war wie in
diesem jahr
auf eine sinnvolle
abgewogener ausgabenpolitik kommt es in
diesem jahr mehr an als denn je
wir wollen mit dieser ausgabenpolitik
und wieder in eine lage versetzen dass
wir den derzeitigen herausforderungen
die durch putins grausamsten
angriffskrieg aufgebrochen sind dass wir
diese bewältigen und das verlangt uns
weiß gott ihnen auch alles ab und sie
herr minister sie möchten zur
bewältigung dieser schwierigen
rahmenbedingungen die wirtschaft mit
ungefähr elf milliarden euro
stabilisieren das hört sich zunächst
einmal ganz viel an aber in wahrheit
sind das lediglich 700 millionen euro
mehr als noch 20 21 und ich bin sehr
skeptisch ob dieses mal den derzeitigen
vor uns liegenden problemen wirklich
ausreichend ist ich habe mal gelernt in
einer krise da muss man eher klotzen als
den kleckern vor allen dingen aber herr
minister habeck muss man sinnvoll
investieren in bereiche wie eben das
rückgrat unserer wirtschaft darstellen
investierende wirtschaftsbereiche wie
heute dazu beitragen dass mit
erheblichen steuereinnahmen auch uns in
der union notwendige klimaschutzprojekte
zukünftig und dauerhaft finanzierbar
sind das sind investitionen wohnen in
innovation in forschung weil hier eben
ganz besonders auch im mittelstand davon
profitiert werden und wenn ich das sagen
darf der mittelstand herbeck der
entwickelt hier nicht für die schublade
der mittelstand entwickelt hierfür die
marktreife weiß auch zwingend
erforderlich ist und ich habe den
eindruck dass ihnen diese
wirtschaftszweige von industrie von
handel von handwerk irgendwie so ein
bisschen
fremd sind ich habe den eindruck sie
müssen sich da erst ein stück weit
nähern glauben sie mir wir wollen gerne
helfen dass das gelingt denn sonst ist
es glaube ich nicht zu erklären dass sie
hier massiv die mittel streichen so muss
das zentrale innovationsprogramm
mittelstand dass die mittelstand bei
innovationen unterstützt mit 35
millionen euro weniger auskommen als
noch 20 21 ein innovationsprogramm gp
haben sie sogar 49 millionen euro
gestrichen gleiches gilt für die
industrielle gemeinschaftsforschung
was aber an ihrem entwurf am
dramatischsten ist dass sie jetzt wonach
der korona krise ausländische touristen
wieder zu uns kommen können dass sie die
deutsche zentrale für tourismus die im
ausland für urlaub in deutschland wird
das in dieser organisation zehn
millionen euro ihres ohnehin schon
knappen sind ask um fast ein viertel
kürzen ich finde das ist schlichtweg die
härte und herr minister das ist auch
einmal fällt entschuldigung erlauben sie
eine zwischenfrage von herrn banaszak
auch die infra wartezeit ist immer zu
knapp
vielen dank herr kollege mattfeldt für
die möglichkeit sie haben gerade gesagt
der minister hätte mit solchen dingen
wie industrie eigentlich nichts am hut
haben sie zur kenntnis genommen dass
gegenüber dem regierungsentwurf ihrer
der unionsgeführten regierung zehn
milliarden euro mehr zehn milliarden
euro mehr für die dekarbonisierung der
industrie in den nächsten jahren
vorgesehen ist damit dass alles klappen
kann und nehmen sie in dem zusammenhang
auch zur kenntnis dass es daran auch
hängt das der energie und klima vorm
wald klima und transformations- fonds
ausreichend ausgestattet ist und kann
ich ihre ankündigung dass jetzt
gekleckert und nicht das jetzt um
kleckern klotzen oder andersrum geht so
verstehen dass sie die angekündigte
klage gegen den nachtragshaushalt
2021 der die finanziellen möglichkeiten
überhaupt erst schafft diese
investitionen auf den weg zu bringen
zurücknehmen werden
geschätzter junger kollege banaszak wir
beide mögen uns ja sehr
aber es ist
es ist so dass wir jetzt hier über den
einzelplan 09 uns unterhalten und wenn
sie den energie und klimafonds
ansprechen freue ich mich denn da habe
ich dann gleich noch ein bisschen
munition mehr weil ich da gar nicht mehr
die zeit für die rede hatte das ist der
energie- und klimafonds der demnächst
200 milliarden euro zur verfügung steht
für bereiche die eben unter corona nicht
leiden bereiche die sowieso schon fast
extrem gut ausgestattet sind und wenn
wir dort vernünftig investieren im
energie und klimafonds sind wir ja bei
ihnen an ihrer seite wenn sie aber in
diesen haushalt hineinschauen dann sehen
sie dass eben wir nicht nur eine
klimaschutzminister haben sondern der
weg ist wirtschaftsminister einer der
größten volkswirtschaften der welt und
er ist nicht nur klimaschutzminister und
er kürzt hier mittel für den für den
mittelstand für die industrie für in
handwerk und für den handel und das
findet sich hier wieder das sind
bereiche das sind bereiche die das
rückgrat unserer wirtschaft darstellt
die sie nicht kaputt machen können und
das sehen wir hier in diesem haushalt
und deshalb ganz deutlich wir gretchen
daran wo es erforderlich ist und hier
ist es erforderlich man kann nicht diese
industriezweige kaputt sparen das geht
einfach nicht
deshalb darf ich sagen das ist ein
schlag ins gesicht die kürzung bei der
tct für die mitarbeiter und mitarbeiter
dort die unter der korona krise mehr als
manch andere gelitten hat es hätte sich
gehört herr minister habe hier diesen
etat richtig aufwachsen zu lassen als
denn hier zu kürzen ich finde das ist
beschämend und ich darf sagen und jetzt
schon ankündigen sie werden von uns
einen sehr klugen antrag dieser richtung
kriegen also ich kenne sie ja auch sie
werden sich das zur gemüte führen und
wir werden darüber sprechen und ich
glaube dann kommen wir auch vielleicht
zu einer vernünftigen lösung denn sie
werden es doch den mitarbeitern dort
nicht erklären können warum sie diese
branche mit über 2 millionen
mitarbeitern keinen zusätzlichen cent
übrig haben aber gleichzeitig klima
investitionen in
biodiversität und den klimaschutz
übrigens ausschließlich im ausland
unterstützen wollen das werden die
menschen eben nicht verstehen und
gewundert das darf ich noch sagen er
habe habe ich mich auch über den fast
halbierten ansatz bei den lng bunker
schiffen ja die verringerung hier die es
planmäßig jahres handelt sich um die
ausfinanzierung eines projektes aber sie
haben es ja selber angekündigt lg ist
die herausforderung und hier jetzt kein
anschlussprojekt anzudocken das ist fast
schon fahrlässig ich glaube ich darf das
auch sagen auch bei energiespeichern
hätte ich mir hier etwas gewünscht wir
müssen doch jetzt haushaltsansätze her
hier fehlen die an zu einem
norddeutschen bereich 16 wir haben hier
noch gar nicht luft nach oben ich glaube
hier sollten wir noch nacharbeiten
aber herr minister ich will auch nicht
nur meckern ich möchte auch loben ich
glaube es ist vernünftig was sie im
bereich der luft- und raumfahrt ihr
gemacht haben das haben wir auch in der
letzten legislaturperiode schon gemacht
dass führen sie fort das ist klug ich
habe mich auch gefreut dass sie bei der
erschließung von auslandsmärkten die
mittel um 145 millionen euro angehoben
haben ähnliches gilt auch für den
wasserstoff auch hier haben sie die
schon von der alten regierung
eingebrachten mittel noch einmal einem
aufwuchs zuteil werden lassen dass es
auch eine kluge sache ja herr minister
habe sie haben jetzt in den beratungen
zeit gemeinsam mit uns parlamentariern
aus diesem entwurf etwas vernünftiges zu
machen sie wissen dass sie mich als
ihrem hauptberichterstatter an ihrer
seite finden bei guten ideen übrigens
alle wird berichterstatter für ihren
haushaltsentwurf vielleicht eine sache
zum abschluss hier haben läuft die
wirtschaft dann läuft es auch mit dem
klimaschutz in diesem sinne freue ich
mich auf tolle beratungen in den
kommenden wochen ich bin gespannt was
dann herauskommt herzlichen dank
andreas mattfeldt schaut freudig in die
nächsten wochen ende april wird dann
zweite dritte lesung sein des
bundeshaushalts
2022 da wird es noch allerlei
verschiebungen geben vielleicht wird
sogar der ergänzungs haushalt noch
angebracht eine abkürzung wollte ich
ihnen noch für alle felder nach wie vor
die meisten von ihnen wissen sie lng
liquefied natural gas also verflüssigtes
erdgas nur 1 600 volumens und dadurch
leichter zu transportieren nina scheer
ist die letzte rednerin in dieser
debatte
auch der gönnerhaft uns eingeräumt dass
wir den haushalt noch verbessern könnten
aber ich muss sie doch noch immer daran
erinnern etwa die nationale wasserstoff
strategie von ihrem ehemaligen von
unserem ehemaligen wirtschaftsminister
herrn peter altmaier vorgelegt hat
gerade mal 13 prozent erneuerbare
energien für wasserstoff im jahr 2030
vorgesehen 13 prozent das war die
handschrift mit der wir zu tun haben
unter ihrer wirtschaftsführung in der
koalition das war einfach nicht in
ordnung
bin ich auch froh dass dieses kapitel
abgeschlossen ist und wir brauchen uns
wirklich keine belehrung von ihnen geben
zu lassen wie nun dieser haushalt auf
den weg zu bringen und wie die
energiewende zuständen ist und ich
möchte auch aufs schärfste zurückweisen
dass hier der eindruck erweckt wird wenn
jetzt mit mühe und not aufgrund der
aktuellen situation allen bekannten
krisen es nur notwendig geworden ist ein
zweites entlastungs paket zu schnüren
und hierbei auch nachtzeiten wieder in
anspruch genommen werden mussten alle
sich hingesetzt haben alles daran zu
setzen dass das ermöglicht wird da fällt
ihnen nichts anderes ein als hier zu
suggerieren der öffentlichkeit zu
suggerieren dass die minister nicht in
der lage sein das dem parlament zunächst
zu präsentieren das ist einfach billig
steigende energiepreise zeigen wie
schnell aus abhängigkeit von fossilen
energien handlungsstränge werden können
und insofern ist auch die energiepreis
krise die eine fossile energie
preiskrise ist
ist ein barometer sie ist ein barometer
für die verwundbarkeit von
volkswirtschaften und diese
fortbestehende abhängigkeit von fossilen
ressourcen muss eben insofern auch vor
dem hintergrund dass russland ukraine
konflikt bis unser des angriffskrieges
von russland als zeitraffer betrachtet
werden die haben ein zeitraffer der uns
schaltstellen eröffnet um jetzt akut und
drastisch zu handeln und eben auch mit
dem zweiten entlastungspaket aber auch
weitergehende maßnahmen zu handeln wir
haben morgen das gas speicher gesetz im
bundestag auch das ist eine reaktion auf
grund der aktuellen situation und das
ist auch natürlich aufs schärfste
zurückzuweisen
dass russland jetzt auf vertragswidrige
weise in rubel die energieimporte
beglichen haben möchte dass es
vertragswidrig das ist keine frage des
alters
energiesicherheit ist zum einen eine
frage der entlastung ich es angesprochen
ich muss auch noch mal kurz betonen 15
milliarden euro wurden bereits
vereinbart das muss doch mal
festgehalten
mit stehen heute beschlossenen folge zu
stellenden maßnahmen werden des weiteren
möglichkeiten seien es sind einmalige
heizkostenzuschüsse auf den letzten
metern noch mal verdoppelt worden 710000
menschen profitieren davon auch die
eeg-umlage die jetzt zur mitte des
jahres vorzeitig abgesenkt wird auch
diese ist natürlich eine enorme
entlastung und herr pelli muss noch
einmal korrigieren das ist jetzt nichts
was irgendwo jenseits der energiewende
sein nein durch die absenkung von
strompreis begünstigen wir auch
wärmepumpen und natürlich ist das ein
bestandteil der energiewende das gab es
nicht
berg gesichert heißt aber natürlich zum
einen wird politisch schnell weiter
voran zu kommen deswegen sieht auch der
in dem thema schutz vorm
transformations- fonds mit der neuen
bezeichnung weitere aufwuchs bevor das
ist ganz klar aber auch regulativ müssen
wir natürlich vorankommen und deswegen
ist es so wichtig dass jetzt schnell ein
großes paket mit dem oster paket kommt
und auch weitergehende maßnahmen dass
wir die hemmnisse beseitigen das
planungssicherheit geschaffen wird dass
die ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
zwischen schnell vorangehen die
erneuerbaren bedienen sie schicken uns
keine rechnungen das sind 31 alt dass
sich die bezahlbare energie
importabhängigkeit bringen uns hingegen
in geiselhaft und darauf müssen wir uns
befreien vielen dank für
nina scheer war das sprecherin für
klimaschutz und energie letzte rednerin
in der debatte in der ersten beratung
des etats für das ministerium
von robert habeck also wirtschaft und
klimaschutzes wird weitere beratungen in
den ausschüssen geben unter anderem im
haushaltsausschuss